all right so Hazel Runners on Linux
now and I'd like to keep it that
way so if you've been following along
you probably know that I have been
setting up continuous integration for
Hazel and just in general focusing on
testing the engine making sure that
things work which turns out is important
who would have thought so in the latest
installment of this Saga I thought it
was finally time to add continuous
integration for Linux just to make sure
that we can continue to build Hazel
successfully on Linux and then later
expand that into actually running the
engine and running tests and making sure
things work so first of all the part of
Hazel supporting Linux this has been
something that has actually been around
for quite a while all thanks to Emily
she came along and joined the team as a
volunteer quite a while back and I guess
she's really into Linux and decided to
make hazel run on Linux so definitely
very thankful for that but what
supporting multiple platforms means uh
you know somewhat unfortunately is that
there's more work to do there there's
you can't just simply write code and
expect things to work in fact I have to
say that even just on a single platform
like Windows the fact that you have
multiple configurations like debug
release and disc even just testing that
even just making sure that you've
written some code build it in debug
build it in release build it in D even
that is something that I feel like a lot
of Engineers just either forget to do or
just don't want to do and that's really
the beauty of continuous integration you
know we have continuous integration of
Hazel using GitHub actions if you want
to learn more about that then I actually
did talk about that quite in depth
showing how I set all of it up in a
previous video which I will have linked
up there so looking at the result of
that you know we have like a commit
going into Dev and you can see that it's
being built in debug release and dist uh
successfully you know and we can
actually look at all of the logs you
know if it wasn't successful for example
you could look at this and be like this
is what went wrong this was the error
which means that you know I mean I would
still probably try and quickly compile
my code in all of the configurations on
Windows you know if I was writing code
just to make sure that I didn't forget
something that might affect a different
build configuration so like a classic
example of that might be I've renamed a
member variable and I've just been
building in release but there was an an
assert that used that old name of the
member variable which now means the
debug is not going to build so whilst I
would still advocate for actually doing
that building yourself manually before
you commit especially if you merge into
Dev so maybe if it's in your own feature
branch and you're planning to like clean
stuff up anyway you know whatever but
once merging that into Dev which is like
our Mainline Dev Branch by the way
instead of me explaining all the
branches if you just go to Hazel l.com
roadmap which is this Miller note board
there's a branches section that explains
like all of our branches and how we use
them so this is the dev branch that I'm
talking about you can see that
everything else is getting merged into
that so this is already coming in handy
but anyway if you do merge into dev then
yeah you should probably test that
anyway but just in case you haven't you
will be caught by CI so actually I think
this is where it literally happened
because there was a commit that I did
did but it broke the debug build and you
know I fixed it and you can see the
build now passes so fantastic but when
you add an additional platform which in
turn will use a different compiler you
know in our case at least all of these
windows builds they're being built by Ms
build which uses msvc which is the
Microsoft like Visual Studio compiler
Linux on the other hand we are building
using clang a different compiler and I
don't know if I really need to explain
this I guess it depends on your level of
C++ experience but even the same
compiler between different versions can
have drastically different results
including some things that will build on
a certain version of the visual studio
compiler but will not build on other
versions of the compiler like that
happens all the time so then if we move
to a completely different compiler of
course there are going to be differences
and of course there are going to be
issues technically if everyone wrote
code that was 100% compliant with the
C++ standard then maybe you would have
less problems because compilers do have
bugs so you know it's possible that
you're perfect but the compiler isn't
however things do get complicated and
definitely not anyone I don't think
writes 100% compliant C++ code that's
just the reality of software development
and so there are lots of scenarios in
which stuff does compile with msbc but
does not compile with clang that happens
a lot and actually that's one of the
reasons why Emily had to spend so much
time getting Linux to build because
building Hazel because building Hazel on
Linux exposed quite a lot of stuff that
was that worked with msbc but did not
work with clang and that code had to be
refactored and some of it was you know
rather complicated the stuff that tends
to not compile is usually you know
templates conexs per expansions like all
of that kind of stuff those are usually
the problem areas that need fixing So to
avoid this problem then what can we do
because the other thing is not everyone
is going to have a Linux computer
sitting around they will then have to
you know pull their code onto test I
mean even if you do that's that's a
little bit of a nightmare but also I
want to stress the fact that like you
know half the team is volunteer
half of the people working on Hazel are
there on a volunteer basis they are not
getting paid to work on Hazel so because
of that one of my goals obviously is to
make sure that working on Hazel does not
really feel like a job to them because
they have their own software development
jobs with all of the kind of corporate
formal annoyances that come with that so
if I'm then making working on Hazel feel
like real work then that's that's just
going to drive them away working on
Hazel should be an enjoyable experience
that's why that's why the volunteers are
there because they like doing it so if I
was to come in and make a mandate such
as like you have to make sure that you
test everything on every platform
manually and you compile it and make
sure it works before you commit I mean
honestly even I don't want to do that so
the solution to making sure that Hazel
does continue to build successfully on
Linux and if it doesn't you know whoever
whoever pushed code that does not
compile on Linux they can then go in and
fix that and they can see what went
wrong they can see the error messages
they can they can deal with that we
obviously need to expand this automatic
windows continuous integration you know
compiling every commit and all
configurations we need to expand that
system onto Linux now interestingly
enough this computer this computer that
is running the windows CI it's right
here in the office you know we talked
about it in the previous devlogs that
computer actually also has Linux on it
it it's a it's dual booting to Windows
11 and a buntu 22 I think and in fact I
use that computer with a buntu to get
like you know Walnut chat compiling on
Linux the server I'll have a video
linked up there but the problem is that
like you know when it was just used for
manual testing that's fine you can boot
up Windows do your testing there boot up
Linux do your testing there but now that
it is like a permanent continuous
integration machine that's running like
the GitHub self-hosted Runner so it can
run the GitHub actions it obviously
needs to stay booted up in Windows so
that it can continue running that
continuous integration without you know
being offline so then ideally what we
would do is we would build another
computer that's just going to be the
persistent Linux you know PC in the
office and then that could run the
GitHub selfhosted Runner and build Hazel
on Linux and then in the future when we
expand this to not just build but also
run tests you know actually run the
Hazel engine and make sure it passes all
the tests we've got like a huge list of
unit like tests as well as visual tests
that will actually try and render things
and make sure they render correctly
that's coming in the future so that's
why we would ultimately want to have
something actually set up in the office
but the reason why I didn't want to do
that right now uh is because of a couple
of reasons first of all our automated
testing is not quite complete you know
we're not doing it for windows at the
moment even that's something that we've
got planned for early next year but then
also the other reason is because I'm
actually in the process of moving
offices because my family and I well my
wife and child we're moving about an
hour away from where we currently live
we're moving to like the outskirts of
the city where it's like nice and pretty
honestly I'm just super sick of the city
and so what I've been doing is I've been
like basically building an office I've
been renovating an existing like
building that we have on that property
and it's going to become like the new
studio Cho office and so I don't want to
build any more computers you know here I
want to move in there and then once
we're there we can have a more serious
setup but I still want to make sure that
Hazel builds properly on Linux
especially for this 20232 release so
what do I do exactly well I thought that
like maybe I could use the runners the
GitHub office like the GitHub hosted
Runners which included storage and
minutes you know I mean you only get 500
Meg and 2,000 minutes per month which
just taking a look at their pricing
calculator here if we do five jobs a day
20 minutes each job which I would say is
a conservative estimate then that's $24
per month which is not terrible however
what I don't like is that this is all
Meed based on minutes and then there's
also the question of storage and then
what if I want other branches to also be
built that's going to use more more
minutes so I don't know whilst I don't
think that's necessarily a bad solution
for now I did have the idea of well why
not just set up a VPS why not just have
a VPS run your Linux continuous
integration because that you know that
just gives you full route access you can
do whatever you want there and it's
going to be much cheaper if we take a
look at hosting as VPS plans which you
guys know I've been using hostinger for
quite a while now and they're always
really nice and generous with hooking me
up with whatever VPS I need they've been
a fantastic partner for Hazel and for
this Channel and they are sponsoring
this video as well so if we take a look
at some of their offerings I mean this
is $8 a month and in fact it's even
cheaper if you use coupon code Cho but
we'll get into that later you know you
get 100 Gig of nvme disc space which my
out is super fast and obviously full
route access and the thing is this is
not Meed based on minutes this is not
you know you have your 100 Gig if you
need more like you can always scale up
by the way super easy to scale up your
plan or scale down your plan if if this
is fine for you this is also two caes by
the way the GitHub one which this is
true C you want four you can get four
not much in fact if we go up to like the
most expensive one it's $22 a month
which is still cheaper than GitHub at
400 GB of dis space and eight cores
which is four times the cores that
GitHub gives you these are different
products and I'm not necessarily saying
you should go for this 100% but to me
this kind of seems just bad I would
prefer to do this so that's exactly what
I did if we go back up here to like the
latest commit or the latest workflow run
for example you can see we now have a
build windows and we have a build Linux
and we can look at that build Linux and
uh obviously you know we can look at all
of the logs here's the actual build log
you can see first it's going to run
setup which runs premake to generate the
make files and then it's just going to
run make to actually build the code so
if you want to set this up yourself uh
you know just go to hosting.com Cho I'll
have the link in the description below
of course pick a plan such as this one
uh and then when you are checking out
just don't forget to use coupon code Cho
because that will give you an additional
discount as you can see this exact plan
by the way is about to be cheaper as
well because hostinger have a Black
Friday sale starting on October 30 and
ending on December 3rd so if you've been
thinking about this then the best time
to get this is going to be right now and
then once you've done that you can just
set up the VPS it's quite simple you can
just pick your operating system pick
your region choose your password stuff
like that and then you'll see this
hosting a dashboard which is lovely very
easy to use here's the IP address from
here you can just SSH into the server uh
and then here we are now from here it's
just a matter of you know making sure
that you have everything properly
installed here like git and clang and
all of the dependencies that you might
need for your specific project so that
is now up and running every single
commit that goes into Dev and master
although if you look at our Branch
structure you can see that Master is is
our release Branch so really like two or
so commits per year will will go into
that Branch Dev on the other hand which
is as you can see is where everything
gets merged into all of those commits
will now get built on Windows and Linux
so we immediately are made aware of any
problems that we might have with
building on all of the platforms that
Hazel supports in all of the
configurations that Hazel supports now
you can see here that there's no D
configuration the reason for that is we
haven't quite made dist work properly on
Linux just yet dist is also a little bit
of a unique configuration so for example
the editor doesn't actually build or run
in disc dist is a special configuration
that we used to actually ship the final
product of a Hazel project so like you
know to ship the game because of that it
actually doesn't include a fair few
things so for example it doesn't include
the Shader compiler which means you
can't build shaders and also just off
the top of my head it doesn't include
ASM ASM is a 3D model library that we
use to import 3D models from a wide
variety of formats such as gtf and fpx
that doesn't exist in the disc
configuration that library is simply not
there it's not linked it's not included
it's not there because Hazel's runtime
uses Hazel's own 3D model format it
doesn't use ASM to import like a gltf
file that you might use during
development when you import it into the
editor it will use Hazel's own 3D model
format which is much more optimized for
the runtime and compiling shaders and
importing 3D models obviously things
that you would want to do during the
development of the game so hence they're
needed by Hazel's editor so that's why D
isn't here it's because it's a bit of a
special configuration we still need to
work through that so then let's take a
look at the workflow file uh and I'll
I'll talk about the changes I've made
again I do go in depth into this in a
different video which I'll have linked
up there so if you're interested in how
I put the windows version of this
together in the first place check out
that video so really the only difference
here is that I've expanded that there
used to be just one job called build now
there's build Windows which continues to
run on Windows and self-hosted but then
there's also a build Linux and what that
does you can see it runs on Linux and
self-hosted so I've added an additional
self-hosted Runner which runs on that
hosting of VPS and we'll talk about that
in a minute here as well so there's
debug and release build configurations
we have the exact same checkout action
the exact same python being set up as
well we're not actually using python
here but we will in the future and then
you can see I'm just making sure that we
set some environment variables namely
the only thing there is the Vulcan SDK
path because that's that's going to be
local specific to that machine and then
we just run premake you know with clang
to generate the make files and then we
just run make and that is it it's really
quite simple at the moment but it does
the job I didn't technically start with
this instead the first thing I did was I
hopped onto that VPS and I just cloned
Hazel from kit myself and I made sure
that it built it definitely wouldn't be
a good idea to just use GitHub actions
and keep committing stuff or keep
rerunning tasks so that it it does this
much easier to just SSH into the server
and do everything there one of the
reasons why again I like this solution
more than using GitHub hosted Runners
now creating the self-hosted runner
again really easy you just switch from
Windows to Linux here and then you just
run all of this and that's it and then I
just set it up to run as a service again
and it was super easy to set up just as
long as your workflow file specifies
that it should run on Linux and
obviously that self-hosted Runner is
tagged with Linux this will just run
magically I have to say this whole
GitHub actions uh system is really
really really good it just works really
well and I haven't had many issues in
fact I had less issues with Linux cuz I
didn't have to do anything like run it
as root or whatever in Windows I had to
do a little bit of uh user playing
around with users that were allowed to
run that GitHub self-hosted Runner but
with Linux it literally just worked
which was fantastic now I will say
whilst you are building this making sure
that it works potentially editing C++
files I I wouldn't just be using the
terminal here instead I'd be using
visual studio code there's this
extension if you type in SSH called
remote SSH by Microsoft I do not know
how I did not know that this was a thing
like this is the most this this should
just come with video judio code it's so
good all you have to do is add a new SSH
host add your VPS you know and then you
just connect to it and then you
literally just get like a normal Visual
Studio code style workspace but like on
that remote server so you can see that
here I've just opened it up to my
actions Runner directory which contains
that GitHub self-hosted Runner that I
downloaded like here's the run script
you know that you would call under work
is where it's actually checked out Hazel
so this is the check out of Hazel that
is going to be doing all of the the
running on and executing my GitHub
workflow on you can hit contrl p and
open like I don't know renderer do CVP
like as if it was just all local control
shift F works if you want to like find
something and of course if you just need
a normal terminal you just open up a new
terminal you can have as many as you
want and like this is just a normal
terminal as if you were you know sshed
in and just using the terminal app so
this of course is great if you're trying
to you know make sure that that we're
inside say this directory which by the
way you can just copy the path and there
we go you know if I'm trying to
continually like make stuff and make
sure that it's actually building
correctly and it's compiling tweaking
the code you know fixing it or being
inside premake and just making sure that
the bill scripts work for Linux in this
case doing that from within Visual
Studio code is just so much better and
in my opinion this is one of those
things that actually makes this quite
viable because otherwise like dealing
with a remote server for you know more
complicated things like game engines
might have been a little bit awkward a
little bit hard but if you've got a
workspace such as this it's just so much
better so yeah I'm sure you all know
about this and I'm just the stupid one
here but I just wanted to share this
because it's it's just amazing and it
made my week so much better all right I
think that's pretty much it that pretty
much summarizes my journey to getting
Linux CI for hazel so I'm really happy
that we now have Windows and Linux
across like all the configurations every
single commit into Dev finally being
actually built and any errors reported
it's definitely advisable to just have
this set up from the beginning I can't
say that it was particularly difficult
to set it up at this stage you can set
it up at at any stage as long as your
actual you know engine builds then it's
not that difficult to just set up a
GitHub workflow file uh and make sure
that you're running through this and
again the next major step is going to be
running this testing this because that's
going to be critical to do across a wide
variety of actual Hardware so just
different gpus as well as obviously
Linux and windows making sure that
features work the same way and we don't
have weird platform specific bugs thank
you guys for watching this video If you
enjoyed it please don't forget to hit
the like button if you have any
questions or comments leave them below
and finally don't forget to check out
hosting is Black Friday sale while it's
still on hosting.com Cho is the link
along with coupon code Cho and I will
see you next time goodbye